ladies and Gentlemen people of the world
wherever you are whatever you are we
have an extremely special guest today
huge guest our biggest thus far and we
can't really believe that she's even
here with us today yeah um she's on a
very tight schedule so the fact that she
made time for this is incredibly
flattering and really cool so without
further Ado you want to introduce yeah
uh ladies and gentlemen uh Ariana
Grande
thanks for coming on yeah thanks for
appreciate
it super cool to have you here sort
of this is just practice for what for
the real
thing you think she's coming on this
show she's already been on the
show my apologies this is the real thing
yeah right so what are we practicing for
the real thing okay the real episode
yeah this is just the cold open yeah
okay this is practice all right Ariana
come on out
here oh my God that would be good that'
be crazy right that would be [__]
good it would be good too bad that's not
happening today it's not happening just
kidding come on out
yeah it's been so long since we spoke a
whole oh my god dude it's been what two
weeks a whole week a week
yeah no transparently ladies and
Gentlemen by the time this is coming out
we just shot the boots episode yeah
which was yesterday so just you know if
you do I was showing some thigh there
yeah so what what H oh was a lot of like
there are some some shots where I'm just
like this and the shorts travel down it
literally looks like you see your dick
and balls no it looks like I'm wearing a
it looks like an upskirt be what it
looks like an upskirt yeah so just like
what just darkness no it just looks like
a
clean a nice like you want to pull it to
the side
almost it's like Supple loin there did
you watch the replay and then you were
like oh
[__] yeah it's kind of a lot of thigh
yeah so it looks like a big diaper at
some moments other times it just looks
like a skirt but you censored it yeah
yeah so the viewers couldn't give that
to the people yeah they don't get to
enjoy that just yet you got to work for
that what do you propose they do to earn
that sign up for TMG studios. TV where
we have the uncensored version the
diaper edit the diaper edit the pull it
to the side
edit if you like cut back and forth and
we just VFX my legs like up by my
head it you wouldn't blink L it halfway
looks that
way that's a view many may be familiar
with why when you're about to oh yeah
yeah yeah we would have had dudes
putting their dick right on the phone
[Laughter]
they' damn I really might have cracked
my phone yeah you did that pretty hard J
JK JK so how's your
night how's it been since the yesterday
the how's the 16 hours been since I've
seen you really intense yeah was it what
happened I got
home figured out some things what did
you figure out YouTube things oh nice
okay guess what dude I couldn't help but
notice you left the
sign here last night yeah I'll take it
I'll definitely take it okay was that a
m just mistake that was actually an
actual mistake that was an actual
mistake that's definitely coming with
okay okay cool you left the Pepsi
machine
though I know that's for here for here
but the Cs I got that for here yeah I
I'm like yeah I'm going to get a couple
straps get it pinned behind my head what
do you think about
that wow Aran a big CS fan that's crazy
so you watch The Gamers 8 finals I know
Saudi Arabia they're buying up all the
sports you can't believe it you see they
actually started construction on the
line on the line they're like you know
futur no they started it yeah look that
up it's [__] crazy I forget how long
it is exactly but like they have a hole
like they're digging a hole for it yeah
and it's like you know 15 miles long or
something like that right on the just
the edge of the desert it's [__]
crazy yeah the line City seen
it the line
project
yeah it's going to be really easy to put
a plane
into what sorry sorry what nothing sorry
just intrusive
[Laughter]
thought all right so how's this thing
work put two big train tracks I think
it's just one I think one big train
track oh there's the world trade in oh
what was that there there's a World
Trade Center inside it there's there's a
replica oh so it's like a game you got
to fly through the whole find the actual
yeah yeah like Star Wars like you have
to go through
the long Corridor to get to hit the
thing at the end bro guess what what I
was sitting there depressed last bonus I
know man it's been a while since I got
one out of
10 wait what on YouTube you got a one
out of 10 we're in there really we're
back on which which video my the one I
posted today one out of 10 how's it feel
pretty good spend a minute spend a
minute I'm holding a trophy when I get
home you like that thumbnail you're
beautiful as you
are yeah how did you make that our
designer is a is a whiz absolute whz
where did you find
them uh she actually she was a listener
of Alina's podcast and she was doing a
bunch of crazy art for that and we were
like join the team gang wow that's so we
brought her on yeah shout out pra
actually it was Al Alina was like dude
this is the most like insane
listener created art I've ever seen wow
elina's pretty immediately like we
should hire her so
yeah sick so is that like a frame from a
music video or something to be honest
reminds me of Jim or something like that
yes to be honest I have no [__] idea
how she did that that's crazy because
yeah what is it Barbie no the origin she
pulled that from an original frame from
the video and if you click what if you
click into that video and you go about
like 2 minutes in don't don't mute it I
don't ever want to hear my
voice um y blast blast it you just saw
you saw you just saw it okay wait go
back I do like a fake out Nord
ad if you just highlight the cursor over
the yeah just keep going keep going
right there that was it that was it she
pulled it from
that that's
wild
damn yeah and then go back
go back to the
thumbnail that's crazy what was her
name nice try dude nice try da you're
watching yeah you know I got some work
for you no no no no
fulltime not a veil yeah not a veil full
time full time really locked in you do
that much design you have 10-e
contract no she actually is fulltime
yeah oh yeah yeah holy [__] yeah that's
awesome we're we're we're building the
next Golden State Warriors of designers
and editors it seems uh green is my
color yeah that's a great that's a great
thumb and I like those too those are
sick and so is the shirt thanks man it's
pretty sick when your boy's looking at
you and he's
like dog you ever thought about wearing
a soft
Olive it would bring out your eyes man
on
God I'm not even capping right now yeah
what color are your
eyes don't look at me she says okay oh
yeah sorry right sorry about that
apologies so apparently she's resting
her vocal cords because she's got a big
show coming up she's resting them
because at the end of episode she's
going to cuss us out yeah in the bonus
she's going to cuss us out that's what
she said yeah so sign up for teamg
studios. TV in order to see
that uncensor moose knuckle as well you
get to see that oh yeah dude yeah
sometimes I do Kelsey's podcast and she
films it from like we have this like
elevated like bed and the last time I
did it I wore shorts and they're like
short like short shorts you sat like
this so I'm sitting like this straight
legs yeah exactly like
this just entirely moose knuckle you
know so the whole time I'm like trying
to put my legs together and I'm like
self-conscious the whole time sitting
like this yeah no for
sure no for
sure no holding the mic is just more com
[Laughter]
for